[Music]
good
what the [__] have you got incredible
luck
[__] say that again you prick
check or bet oh chill the [__] out bro
been doing this all day just calm down
and you get him told adam i'll tell you
take all the time you need paul you're
taking a piss
he's lost his head listen you and you
both
ears just shut the [__] up yeah and you
there's no way
this prick's got an ace so i'm all in
[__] yes adam what are you playing at
it's the red mist man it's got him he
says didn't realize either of you were
still in this hand why are you talking
we're about as in it as you are mate
cool
for [__] sake he's gone all in on the
friend
what is he thinking what a shame oh
pocket queens
lost wins with queens you never had a
chance
go [__] yourself
[Music]
what did i do deserve that just play a
bit of poker
[Music]
this guy i want to learn about him
i want to learn about him
[Music]
you're making this easy for me mate yeah
but you would say that you do know how
to play poker don't you oh shut up man
rory
[Music]
easy
oh he's feeling clever on you i know he
gets a look in his eyes like
my name is laurence i'm going to be all
so serious all of these little looks in
there it's not going to do nothing now
pal
comes down to what's here i'm lawrence
i'm the clever one he's the big dumb
working class one
well i'm afraid not you're done
[__] up go on then
that wasn't the one you needed he's got
a degree in all rory big one
big one first as well do you know what a
degree is good for
absolutely nothing when it comes to
porgal pal
i could see it man just turn over the
cards
he's still out thank you
goodbye just don't spend it on another
car yeah
sure you wouldn't even buy the petrol so
oh awkward
thank you very much i'd have won that
you're up against the flamingo
[Music]
oh actually whoa whoa whoa what are you
doing
what put your chips down yeah but i
didn't mean to do it just
too late now man a chip blade is a chip
please
get them done people can change their
minds not in pork i mean this isn't
[__] football come on
put them down make a difference anyway
right good
[Music]
you're not bluffing you're sure about
that
you haven't got the minerals for this i
know you haven't got the minerals for
this
[Music]
corn then
nothing but you know what i do have
bollocks like a bulldog
thank you more money for me
[Music]
even if i lose this it's like whatever
just can't roll them
[Music]
this is unbelievable
i'll put you all in big mistake
cool don't say i didn't warn you i tried
i'm an honest man
swivel on that judy i'm gonna book a
holiday
i'm gonna ring my wife now tell us a
book
dubai
come on
give us the diamond your pasta
[Music]
congratulations for spending these
winnings
come on man oh hey rory
come on welcome to the holidays
[Music]
you